today we're playing home with sex toys
it's up we were playing sex toys I
actually enjoy certain types of sex toys
I recently got a new vibrator the I
rubbed my ducky waterproof massager it's
literally just a duck but where would
this even go oh this is a vibrate press
here to turn me on oh yes I will
nothing sacred anymore
okay so the lips move you could put that
somewhere what if it gets stuck in there
like I do not a thing it happens it
doesn't get stuck in there no no I don't
know would you put that in your routine
why not that's gonna be looking at you
like I know what you're doing 30
different speed I'm not trying to judge
cuz men will stick their dick in
literally anything but I feel like a
duck is crossing the line goodbye easy
beat egg this is not a sex toy but this
for your butt this is a tanga egg and
basically yeah you put your dick inside
of it it's a dick saw it's a dick sock
and they feel so good
how it feels like heaven I'm not gonna
lie this is uncomfortable to watch it's
uncomfortable to do I'm really gonna
this egg with this banana these
actually can take a lot you know I went
too hard
damn girl see like now I'm just jerking
off a banana yeah and then see how far
you construction Wow wow that's like
average right that what the vagina feels
like to you I don't know I've never put
my thing in a Regina before Oh what look
at you put it on the knee I don't want
to try it you would you mind giving me a
hand okay I'll do that yeah I just need
to reach around what if that's where
dicks actually where there's a whole new
meaning to take a knee right but like
how would this work
naughty naughty boy Santa uh-huh Mikayla
comes with a bush and everything
I understand strap-ons it's just a
curious curious location so this could
be a double penetration thing
gosh go sit on it because some women do
really like anal and you're knee-deep
hey what the is a nipple shocker
nipple clamp shock your lover or shop
yourself this excites people talking
about how their Samsung phones are
exploding if I can't trust
dancing I certainly don't trust those
guys these are for the nips I I'm gonna
have to try this on you bro
you need some mood music let's turn it
on you move my hands but what if it goes
through you to me no lower okay is
shocking I did put it up all the way I
like that but I don't know how I would
feel about that like on my unlike my
dick or anything it doesn't say anything
about putting it on your dick I think
you just like putting things on your day
we don't know about this any of these
toys these are fun I think people who
are single maybe should explore toys
more you can basically put yourself
inside of anything or put anything
inside of yourself that was theme if you
want a egg egg its
whatever tickles your pickle literally
exactly but especially Curly's pickle oh
my god everything felt so good take all
that home
[Music]